welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and the new
trailer for thor love and thunder
finally dropped revealing our very first
look at natalie portman wielding mule
near his thor not only did our girl
natalie get buff as heck she somehow
managed to piece together the fragments
of the hammer back together and is
worthy enough to wield it but how is the
mcu going to bring jane foster back into
the mix after her off-screen breakup
with the god of thunder she didn't dump
me you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping today
i'm going to explain how marvel could
showcase the new thor all the way back
in 2019 taika ytd announced at san diego
comic con that he had been reading the
jason aaron run of thor in preparation
for the fourth installment in the film
series if you're not familiar with
aaron's thor stories let me give you a
quick rundown thor battles gore the
godbutcher which we'll also see him do
in thor 4. but it's not until his
original sin run that we see thor lose
his worthiness of mjolnir in his absence
jane foster is worthy enough to wield
the hammer and becomes thor herself
during 2014's thor and mighty thor and
she's not just girl thor or thor with
titties jane foster is the actual thor
during an interview with yahoo natalie
portman confirmed that thor love and
thunder will be following this storyline
from the comics saying it's based on the
graphic novel of the mighty thor she's
going through cancer treatment and is a
superhero on the side but how will the
events of mighty thor tie into the story
we know from the mcu jane foster has
been absent from the franchise since her
last appearance in thor the dark world
in 2013 and we know that she and thor
broke up off screen some time after age
of ultron eric briefly mentioned in his
thor love and thunder reaction video
that it's possible that we'll see jane
develop cancer due to negative side
effects from exposure to the ether and
the infinity stones and i think that
he's right so let's expand on what that
might look like long before thanos
showed up at the collector's museum on
nowhere to retrieve the ether and
solidify it into the reality stone the
ether was a mysterious force that
existed before the universe itself was
even created in an age before the big
bang and before the formation of the
nine realms the ether was liquefied into
a dark red sludge and wielded by the
dark elves arrays that also predate our
concept of the known universe the dark
elves goal was to use the ether to
change all matter into dark matter and
to revert the universe to the primordial
darkness from which they spawned before
the beginning of time but here's the
kicker about the ether and why it may
have given jane foster cancer when the
ether bonds itself to a living host the
energies of the ether slowly consume it
kind of like a parasite the healers on
asgard use a soulforge or a quantum
field generator for you earth science
folks to determine that the amount of
energy in jane's molecules will kill her
if they don't remove the ether from her
body when the ether alters reality it's
doing so by literally changing the very
molecules of whatever it touches you
know when i'm tired i sure like to play
tank blitz world of tanks blitz is a
free-to-play multiplayer pvp tank
shooter it's available worldwide on ios
android nintendo switch mac os windows
and steam in world of tanks blitz every
battle brings a unique challenge to test
your skills and tactical thinking world
of tanks blitz features cross-platform
gaming that unites players on different
devices in team base 7 vs 7. it has
unique gameplay mechanics like spotting
ricocheting and bullet penetration there
are over 400 vehicles to choose from and
lots of customization so you can stand
out the game is constantly updated with
events and new gameplay mechanics world
of tanks blitz offers you a gameplay
experience unlike any other game out
there find out why millions of gamers
worldwide play blitz every single day
click the link in this video's
description to download the game and
join 170 million players worldwide what
are you waiting for start your engine
although the ether is removed from
jane's body by malekith towards the end
of thor 2 jane still has one more major
molecular shakeup to go jane foster is
one of the many people who were blipped
out of existence when thanos snapped his
fingers and we still have no idea what
the side effects of popping in and out
of existence due to your system the
unfortunate reality of cancer is that it
occurs when your cells grow abnormally
mutating in a way that makes you sick
it's entirely possible that shaking up
jane's cells multiple times plus
infecting her with the purest most
potent form of an infinity stone is
likely what causes her cancer to develop
in thor love and bender but this
formerly parasitic connection to the
ether may also explain why jane foster
becomes thor eric also pointed out in
his reaction video that the trailer's
video description on marvel
entertainment's youtube channel reads to
combat the threat thor enlists the help
of king valkyrie korg and ex-girlfriend
jane foster who to thor's surprise
inexplicably wields his magical hammer
mjolnir as the mighty thor the word
inexplicably here really says a lot it
tells us that despite all of his
encounters with magic throughout the
nine realms and beyond he still has no
idea how jane was able to reassemble his
broken hammer and wield it as thor that
inexplicable magic may come from the
long lasting side effects of exposure to
the ether and it could explain how jane
was able to summon the fragments of
mjolnir and reassemble them in the
comics the hammer itself calls to jain
from its location on the moon where thor
dropped it after he lost his worthiness
in original sin number seven while thor
is battling nick fury in space fury
whispers something in his ear that
causes him to question his status as a
deity and lose his worthiness to lift
mjojnir we later find out that what he
whispered was gore was right which
really messed thor up in the aftermath
of everything he went through during the
thor god of thunder run when jane foster
picks up the hammer for the first time
in 2014's thor issue number one she
transforms into thor regains her
strength and is able to kick ass as the
goddess of thunder but unfortunately
each time she transforms the
transformation neutralizes the effect of
chemotherapy on her body and her cancer
returns tenfold as long as she continues
to transform into thor she cannot heal
and is slowly dying with each change
once again the storyline from the comics
seems to fit in with what we know about
the ether's effect on immortal while the
ether was inside jane she was filled
with so much power that she couldn't
even be touched by anyone the dark
matter perceived as a threat to its host
but at the same time the ether was
killing her from inside her very
molecules which is similar to the
outcome of jane wielding mjolnir in the
comics to put it simply whenever jane
gets powers in the comics and so far in
the mcu those powers end up making her
very sick but how exactly will jane
repair the broken pieces of mjolnir when
it calls to her the answer to this may
lie in another jason aaron series war of
the realms in which jane recovers the
broken hammer of the war thor a lost
relic from a dead universe when she uses
its very last throw it shatters
completely and the pieces of war thor's
hammer return to jane the energies
trapped within it are bonded to jane and
she later learns that the hammer of war
thor was one of the many forms that
could be assumed by unduchar the all
weapon in the comics undesired the
all-weapon is formed from the shattered
pieces of a mjolnir displaced from the
ultimate 1610 universe and its power is
that it's able to transform into any
type of weapon the person wielding it
needs i think it's possible that the
shards of mjolnir summon jane foster due
to her previous mystical connection to
ether sometime after hella destroyed it
during the events of ragnarok and when
they reassembled they formed the
undercharm which is what we see jane
holding at the end of the love and
thunder trailer in the mighty thor comic
run we learned that jane was able to
adjust to being thor because she picked
up on his moves while she was watching
him throughout all of his battles and
that she's able to take the persona and
truly make it her own if taika waititi
chooses to follow this specific part of
the storyline jane could have reformed
mjolnir from the underground because
that was the weapon she became familiar
with in the first two thor movies
something that i personally love so much
about the mighty thor series is that
jason aaron wrote jane foster thor to be
her own character completely separate
from her pretty boy boyfriend although
she was directly inspired by thor she
takes what she learns from him and
forges her own identity in an interview
with aaron he commented on the
separation between the two characters
saying she's not she thor or lady thor
she's not thorica she is thor this is
the new thor if you check out the
inscription on mjolnir it reads
whosoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the power of thor
this is why jane foster isn't just girl
thor she's the real thor which means
that thor isn't just the name of a
character it's also a title in the
unworthy thor we find out that thor
odinson doesn't even go by the name thor
anymore and wants only to be called
odinson because he's no longer worthy of
the hammer the ability to wield the
hammer is what makes a hero thor and
that's why jane foster is the real deal
in the comic run and will be in the
upcoming movie based on photos released
from the set it's safe to say that
natalie portman is truly embracing the
opportunity to be her own thor look how
incredibly jacked this girl is what you
want mighty thor to drink and fight what
you need mighty thor to [ __ ] all night i
think that this is the strong side of
jane foster that we'll see when she
picks up the hammer and the side effects
of her cancer are no longer visible this
trailer did a great job of leaving a lot
to the imagination so we haven't seen
what jane foster looks like outside of
her thor persona but my guess is that
this movie will follow a similar path
that the comics laid out there's
absolutely no telling what kind of
implications that the multiverse of
madness will have on all of this and i'm
not ruling it out that this could also
be a thor variant from another
multiverse that happens to follow
aaron's comic storyline while the
original jane from the mcu is just
somewhere else but based on portman's
confirmation that her character in love
and thunder will follow the cancer plot
from mighty thor i'm leaning towards the
theory that we're gonna see jane foster
become thor's one of the many side
effects of coming in direct contact with
a liquefied infinity stone follow me on
instagram and twitter whitney puppy
follow new rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you